bienvenido a france 24 señor pachano
eeuu y la unión europea endurecieron sus
medidas contra nicaragua mientras que
otras potencias como rusia y china-
respaldan a ortega pero que tantas
implicaciones tienen esas sanciones o
ese respaldo en la realidad nicaragüense
gracias buenos días
tienen en efecto las sanciones
evidentemente tanto en el plano político
como en el plano económico pero yo creo
que
surtirán un poco efecto internamente en
nicaragua debido a que nicaragua en este
momento ya se ha confirmado como un
gobierno no democrático podría decirse
que se trata de una dictadura más en
américa latina y a ese tipo de gobiernos
estas sanciones no les afectan
significativamente sobre todo si tienen
socios como los que usted acaba de
señalar en otros países en rusia china
etcétera en términos me refiero en
términos de su sustentabilidad económica
pero pero y para con esto concluyó es
preocupante que en américa latina no
tome las no ejecuten algunas sanciones
que pueden hacerlas por ejemplo
basándose en la carta democrática de la
oea podría muy bien
y sancionar al gobierno de ortega por
haber excluido a la oposición en estas
elecciones y por hacer unas elecciones
caudales y usted dice que estas
sanciones no tienen muchos efectos y que
el gobierno continuará a propósito de
esto cuáles son los impactos nacionales
que puede tener este cuarto mandato
consecutivo de daniel ortega
y se va a fortalecer en el gobierno va a
profundizarse quizás algunos episodios
de corrupción que ha habido creo que el
tema fundamental que que está en el
fondo de esto es no solamente el
gobierno autoritario y la exclusión de
cualquier forma de oposición sino
también un gobierno que está basado
fuertemente en
en la corrupción en un manejo arbitrario
de los recursos públicos y creo que eso
va a ser se va a profundizar con esta
con esta elección irregular de ortega y
su esposa y como impacta en la política
latinoamericana que ortega continúa en
el poder después de más de 15 años
e impacta negativamente porque
evidentemente es un atentado contra la
democracia pero se puede quizás ver un
aspecto relativamente positivo y es que
países que se suponía que podían haber
apoyado a esta reelección de ortega no
lo han hecho por lo menos no
abiertamente me refiero en los casos por
ejemplo de argentina o de el perú que
recientemente han tenido gobiernos de
izquierdas digamos o que tienen
gobiernos de izquierdas y que han tenido
más bien una posición de utilidad
cuidadosa al respecto hierro puede ser
un buen síntoma pero hace falta una
posición mucho más clara